الدولي
عندما تحاط او يساهم في بناء الدوله
الوطنيه
العلماء
ومبدعون طبعا تسعى للخلود بشكل الاشكال ثم
ان المجتمع يعيش حالي من الطمانينه
الطمانينه الاجتماعيه وهذه الطمانينه ايضا
تنتج المزيد من المعرفه الان نلاحظ امام
الوباء لان الان نحن امام غير روسي انت
كتبت كتاب بالاشتراك
بالاشتراك حول هذا الموضوع
ومن ضمن الاسئله التي كانت تحاصرنا او
تحاصر بعدها هي
هناك قلق اصبح قلق حقيقي لدى الانسان مفيش
طمانينه ليست هناك طمانينه كما ذكرت لدى
الفرد
هناك خوف من المستقبل
ليس في بلاد العربيه ولكن في العالم كله
زاد من هذا القلق الذي تحدث عنه اوه هذا
الاكتئاب الذي اصبح مزمنا هو من وباء الى
وباء بالوباء الى حرب الحرب اليوم الروسيه
وانا متاكده انها حروب اخرى
ومتاكد ان الفيروس وقلت هذا الكلام اكثر
كتبته نعم انها الفيروسات لن تنتهي
وبالتالي هناك
تتمسك باطروحه همم للتخلص
كثير من الخيرات تكفي لاربع كواكب قد
الارض اذا تم توزيع عادل عادل ولو واحد
بالمي من العدل صح صح وساح المجال للعمل
للكثيرين ما بحاجه يعني في حاجه بهذا
الفناء